GOOD AFTERNOON OF. THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE BE
ADVISED OF AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
BEING MADE IN IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED.
MATTER SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE.
CUNNINGHAM HERE.
PEROT.
CARILLO.
FRIEDMAN.
NAZARIAN PRESIDENT.
SOLACE PRESENT WALDRON.
LEVINE FROM HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. OF.
I AM PULLING AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE FROM TODAY'S AGENDA
JUST TO PERMIT SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT.
APART WITH THAT CHANGE WE DO
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA.
IS OUR MOTION THE CONSENT AGENDA
MINUS AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
MOVE BY MR SOLACE CONSECUTIVE
AYE MR CUNNINGHAM. AMENDED
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE. BROUGH FINE
BROUGH AYE KOREA AYE CARILLO
AYE.
FRIEDMAN NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA I SOLIS. SOLIS AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE LEVINE
FROM.
FONG AYE. MEMBERSHIP PASSED. THE
MEASURES PASSED AND I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH THE SCHOOLS WITH THE
SUBJECT